this is something I thought was so great
so when they're playing Lakers in the
first final series did they send their
doubles uh
no when they're playing the Lakers the
Bulls are playing laughs right in their
first fight right exactly right
now who was originally on magic Michael
Michael Michaels on magic of course
Michael wants to play magic he's been
looking up to magic constantly in this
documentary he's referencing I wanted to
be in the same conversation as Merida
magic right he goes he goes well he
doesn't say I think the documentary says
we switch Scotty on to magic and then
Jordan goes and that changed a series
yeah man Jordan is the most competitive
person on the [ __ ] planet if that
don't show you to respect he has for
Scotty's D this is multiple all
defensive team
this is multiple defensive player of the
year not talking to Scott I'm talking
about Jordan Jordan was mr. Locke you
two [ __ ] up yeah he got a Defensive
Player of the Year he's the only Doug
Doug he's the only goat person that can
think of it has a Defensive Player of
the Year magic don't got one whenever
you don't got one LeBron don't got one
yeah I mean eventually maybe your guy
Kawhi if he's in that discussion
yeah hundred percent right now that's
the only game for him to say yo this guy
doesn't have any defensive player of the
years but just sacrifice my ego that's
another time now that you tell him I'll
sacrifice an ego it's a one-on-one
matchup with a [ __ ] ring me and magic
this is the guy want I'm locking this
[ __ ] up and I'm gonna score on
him all day that's what you got to be
thinking if you're Jordan you got to
check you but if Phil says yo we strut a
little bit in game one let's try this
switch for you to say yeah I'm cool with
that that's a that's a big swallow of
the ego also like right I know what
Scotty does in practice plays let's let
him do it a magic here this is what I
realized about Jordan into his [ __ ]
greatness man and [ __ ] is so rare his
ego was wrapped around the ring mm-hmm
not what he was doing to get the ring
right what it took to get the ring
yeah and if it took him sacrificing
touches all the sudden that's what's
most important if it took him passing
ball the [ __ ] John Paxson that's what
we do if it took him letting Scotty
guard the toughest person on the other
team that's what we do cuz my ego is the
Rings not a personage guy you're
competing with to be the goat that's it
fine [ __ ] it let's win that's Hugh dog
if you're talking about people who want
to be goats
I remember Damien lemon homie of ours he
talked about like years ago he says
anybody that's in a goat conversation
that's a massive ego you're dealing with
massive use so for you to swallow your
ego with another goat and you're
competing for the first time in your
life and you can take that [ __ ] title
and say you know what the real title is
more important than this temporary goat
thing let's go get that what did he say
what did he say when that he was
describing it this is not those so dope
he goes it changed everything when
Scotty started picking up magic 94 feet
yeah and he goes and I knew it worked
because I saw him doing the practice
yeah now who do you think he saw him do
it again I practice him yeah yeah yeah
so if he knows how great he is and
having Scotty guard him 94 feet is a
pane of [ __ ] ass he's like Oh magic
about to get this [ __ ] work yeah it's
like [ __ ] sometimes you want
that glory so much but the ability to
just go not this is better for the
situation right now it's rare it's hard
it's rare it's hard but that's true
greatness
there's no 1 1 2 check it yeah
[Applause]